well we've seen another really
resounding defeat for the anti-abortion
crowd the Supreme Court yesterday said
that no you can't require in Louisiana
doctors who perform abortions to have
admitting privileges at area hospitals
that this effectively violates roe v
wade which is the precedent of note and
thus reminds us why this question of roe
v wade comes up so often when new
potential Supreme Court justices are
being vetted and questioned and what is
particularly interesting about this
decision is that it was a 5-4 decision
where the five the majority was made up
of the four more liberal justices and
Chief Justice John Roberts a moderate
conservative certainly no doubt about it
and we're going to talk more about Chief
Justice John Roberts and his legacy and
is sort of placed within the Supreme
Court on Thursday but for today I want
to talk about this decision that this
really is an important defeat for the
anti-choice movement that seeks to just
ban abortion make abortion illegal
despite the reality of course that
banning abortion reduces legal abortion
maybe at least in the state where it's
banned but it does not actually reduce
the number of women who figure out a way
to terminate a pregnancy and that's
another story that we've talked about
quite a bit on this program so the
reason this is an important decision is
that this is a common way to try to
restrict access to abortion the way it
works in this Louisiana law that was
struck down by the Supreme Court
yesterday and in other states the game
that they play essentially is you you
don't ban abortion per se but you
require doctors who perform abortions to
have admitting privileges at nearby
hospitals and the anti-abortion people
say that this is that the reason you do
this is well if a doctor performs an
abortion
and the patient needs to be hospitalized
it's important that the doctor have
admitting privileges so that that doctor
can continue providing care in the
hospital for the hospitalized abortion
patient now all of this is part of the
ruse that includes making abortion seem
like a far more risky medical procedure
than it actually is so a few realities
that we should keep in mind number one
hospitalizations after abortion are very
very rare number two even if one were
necessary a hospitalization the patient
would still be able to get care even if
the doctor that performed the abortion
doesn't have admitted admitting
privileges at the local hospital and
number three there are bureaucratic
reasons that sometimes make it difficult
for doctors who perform abortions to get
those admitting privileges so this is
essentially a trick from the anti-choice
crowd to make abortions more difficult
to obtain and maybe to dissuade people
from seeking them out in general so
understand how crazy this is five
doctors in all of Louisiana provide
abortions two of them have obtained
admitting privileges one in New Orleans
and one in Shreveport the Shreveport
doctor says he can't handle all of the
work alone and the trial judge concluded
that what this law in effect does is
reduce Louisiana to a single doctor in a
single clinic in New Orleans and that is
in practice a violation of roe v wade
that is ultimately what the Supreme
Court found that the roe v wade decision
from 1973 which is the precedent for so
much of the discussion about abortion
today would in practice be violated if
this law requiring admitting privileges
at local hospitals were to remain the
law of the land so this is relevant for
a few different reasons number one Chief
Justice John Roberts a George W Bush
appointee previously favored abortion
restrictions in two other abortion
related
we're going to talk more about him
momentarily but in this case john
roberts coming over with the majority in
defense of abortion rights number two
this is huge because everything is just
going wrong for this administration
donald trump as you may know now claims
to be against abortion he was in favor
of a woman's right to choose i believe
is for 67 or 68 years of life his
evangelical followers have fallen for it
hook line & sinker
I guess they believe Trump is now
against abortion and this is another
decision that goes against Donald Trump
stated wishes if we believe that those
are actually his which wishes now let's
talk about Chief Justice John Roberts
because this is really for me the the
crux of the discussion that now is going
on on Friday I'm sorry on Thursday I'm
going to get into more detail about
whether Chief Justice John Roberts is a
moderate or a conservative of course he
was selected by george w bush but what I
really want you to understand about this
decision and the decision on daca last
week where John Roberts was also on the
side of we're not going to remove daca
for the reason the Trump administration
wants it removed these are technical
decisions these are not decisions where
John Roberts is coming over to the left
so to speak on the merits of abortion or
on the merits of daca what I mean by
that is in the daca case for example the
Trump administration just bungled their
case the Trump administration tried to
end daca by saying Barack Obama didn't
have the authority to put daca in place
via executive order the Supreme Court
said that's not a good argument the
supreme court john roberts they
correctly found that Obama did not
overstep Authority but it was not a
decision on the merits of daca and
similarly with this abortion decision
John Roberts is saying in a technical
sense the Louisiana law would violate
the precedent set by roe v wade it's a
technical decision it's not a decision
on the merits now will we take it of
course we will but what's important to
understand I mean look at even the LGB
discrimination case Roberts correctly
identified in a technical sense if you
allow an employer to discriminate on the
basis of sexual orientation or gender
identity by definition it is a
discriminatory act on the basis of sex
which is banned so what John Roberts did
it doesn't mean he made the wrong
decisions
it means he is simply getting the
technical question right it shows us
actually how insane the court is that
these decisions were not nine to zero
this decision on abortion should have
been nine to zero the law that Louisiana
wanted to pass on abortion obviously
violates roe v wade it should have been
a 9-0 decision so the message here
should not be who cares about judges we
got the right decision anyway even with
Chief Justice John Roberts who came over
and joined the liberal majority the
decision should have been nine to zero
and it shouldn't come down to one center
right justice deciding Oh precedent
matters precedent matters that's why we
need Joe Biden and not Donald Trump
choosing more justices because this
should have been should have been a 9-0
decision and then on Thursday we're
going to talk a little bit more sort of
about the political orientation of Chief
Justice John Roberts and other justices
on the court